[Music]
did you to the movie 20 minutes late
miss the previews don't worry it takes
another four and a half minutes for the
movie to start despite not getting much
sleep because of her snoring husband
Josh Renee still looks like she could
win a beauty contest family moves to a
new house horror movie cliche mother and
son matching pajamas mother listens to
baby monitor and clearly hears an evil
voice but instead of running upstairs to
see if her baby is okay she decides that
her investigation is better served
downstairs but silly practical jokers
these ghosts are ha the director of this
movie has to go to detention twice and
look the creepy doll from saw is drawn
on the chalkboard
why isn't there also a drawing of Kevin
Bacon killing people and avenging his
son's death on this chalkboard no no
don't bother there's no reason for you
to make the frightening discovery I'm
about to make with no witnesses in the
room the fact that you don't seem to
have any neighbors pacing pacing pacing
now it's time to go into the room for no
reason and reach for Renee even though
the vessel I need is Dalton I admit I'm
not an expert on ghosts kids but what is
the purpose of standing here in the
corner then running off to the living
room to play an old-timey record and
dance to it alternate between visibility
and invisibility and generally just make
a nuisance of yourself what an asshole I
want to start Muldoon your other
children are with Lorraine right I mean
we didn't care about those kids anyway
so lost where
in a place that I call the further
couldn't you have named it something a
lot cooler he's just left us with a
physical body an empty vessel and there
are entities that know this because they
can smell it that's why they're gathered
around him yes these dead things could
smell Dalton's living empty vessel
that's why they waste their time turning
on record players downstairs and
appearing out of nowhere and generally
making a nuisance of themselves there
are other entities who are malevolent
and have a more insidious agenda hey
that's the title of the movie to cross
over from their realm it takes time it
takes energy far be it for me to
understand the time difference between
the living world and the not-so living
world but this kid has been in a coma
for more than three months it seems like
his living body should be easily
possessed now especially by a demon as
powerful as this one if anything
wouldn't this backup Josh's idea that
the paranormal investigators are
probably frauds they easily could have
seen these pictures and drew something
relevant based off of them but he wants
to call them back after this also I find
it hard to believe that Renee never once
mentioned that the drawing the
paranormal team drew looked exactly like
the ones her child drew and had been
hanging in his room for months oh come
on
wait why is this random ghost trying to
french-kiss Renee I mean I don't blame
him actually I just thought demons
needed an empty vessel to actually do
anything physical did the rules change
why are demons so easily removed by
yelling at them it's amazing this camera
picked up footage of the demon but
somehow didn't pick up anyone else that
was in the room or all the other demons
that were apparently walking around
during that scene we found out earlier
that the worthless kids are being
watched by Lorraine but who's watching
them now I mean I assume it's a
babysitter but I have serious doubts
that anyone else exists in this movie
other than the people we've seen so far
it's no accident that your son is a
gifted traveler the ability was handed
down to him so the ability to travel is
genetic it seems like at least one
horrible demon over millions of years
would have been able to enter an empty
vessel and lay waste to the entire world
if that was the case at first I thought
it was a camera problem seriously Josh's
mom knew what was wrong with Dalton and
had proofed the whole time and just kept
it to herself for some stupid reason but
I thought these ghosts were attracted to
empty vessels why would this hag be
hanging around a kid who isn't
travelling his vessel isn't empty in
these pictures
if these demons can be picked up by
regular cameras then why does this
family picture with Dalton not have a
demon smirking behind it suppress
your memory and your ability to astral
project was the only way to stop her
from getting into you how did Josh
suppress his memory to astral project if
he forgot he could do it wouldn't his
subconscious just to figure it out all
over again
I advised Lorraine to hide them to stop
taking your picture to just let you
forget did that advice also include
keeping important information from him
and his son started doing the same thing
why doesn't Elise need the mask with the
tube for this job you can bring lanterns
into the demon world and if this Lantern
could be taken into the spirit world is
it astral projecting do lanterns have
adventures can they pass this skill onto
baby lanterns is Josh as a kid dead this
isn't his subconscious or anything he
completely left his body so why is his
kid self wandering around in the spirit
world god knows how long the demon world
has existed but they decided to build a
nice little house in the middle of it
because demons need a home too he's in
he's in you mean just now the further
forgot to pay their electric bill is
this the demon world's bouncer you can
be found you're stronger you are the one
alive get away from me really that's all
it took to fend off the demon a little
pep talk and a street fighter move are
these chairs that are stacked in the
background for a a meetings or something
nah sometimes a picture of a horse is
just a picture of a horse okay so now
this kid is chained in the further and
he's been in a coma traveling around the
spirit world for three months and if
this were inception then the time he
spent the world is probably like decades
or centuries or something this is the
slowest dumbest demon possession ever
James Wands fear of marionettes rears
its ugly head again while the demon
waits to enter Dalton's empty vessel he
passes the time with his favorite
hobbies puppeteering and sharpening his
claws this is real none of this is real
are you kidding me
the whole reason we even got to this
point is that it's real also with none
of this is real Howard Josh and Dalton
imagining the exact same things
how did Josh imagine these Janes and
furthermore how convenient is it for
these to be imaginary chain so that
Dalton can escape
well who gives a shit it's not real it's
kind of hard to believe a demon who was
peacefully sharpening his claws of
indigo could turn into such a monster
she's worse helpful kid Josh when you
need him
so this ghosts plan was to mysteriously
open a drawer and just when someone is
about to close it reach out and grab
that person are these ghosts like trying
to join a frat or something
Stephen Lorraine go check on Dalton what
go check on Dalton Dalton
I know specs has freaked out but really
this command takes three times to
register they're crossing over into our
world I thought they already crossed
over like several times during the movie
remember apparently ghosts can be
prevented from advancing as long as you
close the door on them somehow this door
became locked since Josh left her can't
he just pretend it's open and you know
open it I mean what's preventing this
demon from taking Dalton right now he's
hiding behind a bed in an unphysical
world why doesn't the demon take him
already and what did the demon just
decide to leave no of course not
demons who desperately want to living
hosts need to make things scarier and
pop out of nowhere to accomplish their
goals not only that but also make it
easier for the victim to escape I hear
if you look at this woman one way she's
an old hag but look at her another way
and she's a young pretty girl gazing in
the distance well everything seems
proper here God Hilda the demon to go
away which is their greatest weakness of
course she went away which is weird when
we find out that she actually didn't
that's probably what a kid needs after
being asleep for over three months a
blaring hot spot light in the face the
way this kid eats spaghetti they really
can't hear all this yelling not that big
of a house
yep that's definitely a dead face so at
least knew that Josh had probably been
possessed by a demon and thought the
best thing to do was take a picture of
him knowing that that would probably
anger the demon couldn't she have just
started mumbling some psychic she maybe
tried to get the demon out and if it
turns out he wasn't possessed then who
cares if she looks stupid doing it she
could have just said oh sorry you know
psychic I'm right here
obvious equal is obvious
[Music]
you can't touch me
jeepers creepers where'd you get
sometimes
[Music]
with perfect I went through it frame by
frame by frame
my car